mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
construct a circle with a radius equal
to one
from a point on the circle construct
another circle whose radius is also
equal to one
inscribe a square where the two circles
overlap
solve for the area of the square
i thank nibidan mukherjee for suggesting
this problem and it also appeared on the
2019 senior mathematical challenge
conducted by the ukmt
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we'll get started by focusing on the
square and the region where the two
circles overlap
draw a radius from one center to the
opposite corner of the square
since it's a radius of the circle its
length will be equal to one
now connect the two centers of the two
circles
this will bisect the side of the square
if this length is x then this length
will also be equal to x by symmetry
consequently the entire side of the
square will be equal to 2x
now consider the distance between the
two centers
it's the radius of each circle therefore
its length will be equal to one
so half of the distance will be equal to
0.5
we can then consider the distance from
the center of one circle to the opposite
side of the square this will be equal to
0.5 plus x
we then focus on this right triangle
in a right triangle as everyone knows a
squared plus b squared is equal to c
squared
as manjul bhargov a fields metal winner
explains
the pythagorean theorem is clearly the
wrong name for this rule
egyptians had knowledge of it the
indians stated it and the chinese were
the first to prove it
therefore i will be referring to it as
the goku theorem which is what the
chinese call this rule
using the gogu theorem we have point
five plus x the quantity squared plus x
squared is equal to one squared
we'll simplify this formula and we get
the quadratic equation 2x squared plus x
minus 0.75 is equal to zero
we'll then use brahmagupta's quadratic
formula to solve for x
we substitute in the proper values and
we simplify this formula
x will be equal to negative one plus or
minus the square root of seven all over
four
since x is a length we want x to be
greater than zero so we'll reject the
negative solution
we're almost done
we've solved for the value of x and now
we want the area of the square
the side of the square will be equal to
2x and therefore the area will be equal
to the quantity 2x squared
we substitute in the value for x and
simplify to get the answer of 4 minus
the square root of 7 all over 2
and this is approximately equal to 0.677
it's a fun geometry problem and you have
to work through a little bit of algebra
as well
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]